[Music]
oh man this is exciting this is my first
art studio conference by the way guys
yeah I'm pumped I I'm a big fan of our
studio the company and I think you guys
know why it's probably same reasons that
you're here so today what we're gonna be
doing is talking about our for business
so that's kind of where I specialize I'd
marry up business with data science my
company's business science so you can
probably guess how I got the name
business plus data science merger - you
got it all right so what we're gonna be
talking about today is a lot of work
flow we're gonna be talking about how to
solve a specific business problem it's
called employee attrition and it ends up
being a huge problem for businesses it's
a big dollar figure fifteen million
dollars per year and we'll talk a little
bit about how I came up with that number
but more importantly what we're gonna be
doing is we're gonna be showing how the
different tool sets including the tidy
verse my favorite modeling package h2o
and also shiny combined to really help
us solve this business problem so I'll
be your host again my name is Matt Dean
Cho I am the founder of business science
an educational company I'm a lover of
our I've been using it for quite a while
now and even contributed some open
source packages as well probably the
most popular of which is tidy quant and
I do dabble in finance well but really
I'm an educator of data science I
specialize in teaching data science I
both do on-site workshops at companies
and also what I've done is created an
online platform called business Science
University where students can come and
take a range of courses that really up
level them accelerating their careers so
oh and one more thing one of my special
passions is converting business people
to data scientists so I just want you
guys to know if you are a business
person in the audience you don't need a
PhD to be a data scientist I'm just
throwing that out there
all right so agenda for today we're
gonna be talking about a few different
things the fifteen million dollar per
year problem that's gonna be our focus
we're focusing on a business problem its
employee attrition and we'll find out a
little bit more about what that means
the second thing and this is what I'm
super excited about I'm unveiling a new
shiny web app that we're going to be
teaching in the 300 series course and
part of our program at business Science
University it's part of the data science
for business program so you guys are
gonna see it first right here at our
studio it's awesome and just one other
thing about that app just want to give
credit to Kelly O'Brian
she's the one who developed them so
she's a studio employee and I work with
her quite a bit then we're gonna talk
about the internals of the app the data
science workflow what powers this app
the tidy verse we're gonna talk about
h2o and also another package called a
line that I'm very excited about and
then finally we're gonna pull it all
back together and talk about learning
are and how you guys yourselves can
figure out how to do all this stuff that
I'm teaching you okay
so that fifteen million dollar per year
problem so you guys might recognize this
gentleman's face Bill Gates he was once
quoted as saying you take away our top
twenty employees and overnight we
Microsoft become a mediocre company so
let's dissect what he's saying take away
he's talking about a concept called
employee attrition employee turnover top
20 he's talking about high performers
this is the top 20 people in his company
and often what we find is the 80/20 rule
applies top 20 percent of employees in a
company tend to generate about 80
percent of the results so you really
want to do what you can to preserve and
keep and retain those high performers
otherwise your company is going to
become a mediocre company so let's dive
into this a little bit further I want to
talk about this curve it's called the
economic value of an
over time it looks a little bit like
this so we'll see that there's four
different boxes up here the first box is
the curve so when an employee just
starts at a company they represent that
green dot there right at the beginning
so time has not elapsed and actually
what is happening is that company is
investing and actually losing money
having you as part of that company and
that's an investment that they're making
in you so they have to provide you
training mentorship they have to
integrate you and it takes a while to do
this before you can become a productive
member of that company then eventually
you make it to the second box and this
is what's called the break-even point so
as you gradually get to that point where
you begin to start generating returns
for that company and they call that the
return zone so you've got the investment
zone you've got the return zone and that
process can take as little as three
weeks for you know jobs that aren't
overly difficult or for highly technical
jobs it can take upwards of a year or
longer so that's the type of investment
that that company is making in you so
what happens when a person decides to
quit that's what this third box
represents so that employee has become a
productive member of the company they're
generating returns doing really good
work and then all of a sudden they
decide to quit and that could be because
they've you know they hate their boss
that could be because their work-life
balance is all out of whack
or they may just not be like the the
work that they're doing and what ends up
happening is when that person quits that
line immediately dropped down to zero
and then it extends for a period of time
and eventually that company decides to
replace that that person typically and
then that cycle repeats itself
so there are reinvesting in the new
person getting them up to speed and it
takes a while before they get to the
return zone so as you can see in box
number four
we've got lost time and lost
productivity this is what you want to
avoid especially for high performance
so there's two different types of
attrition and we're gonna focus on
trying to prevent your high-performing
employees from leaving
so not all employees are created equally
some employees just never quite get
there and that's what this first box
here is what we call necessary attrition
and this could be because that that
person you know it just might not be a
good fit for the culture of the company
may not mesh well with it might be a
poor job fit whatever reason they're
they just you know don't quite cut it
and it's okay to lose these people but
what you really want to prevent is the
right-hand box which is bad attrition
and this is when you have high
performers that have generated returns
you don't want to see them leave the
organization so you can actually assign
a dollar figure to this particular
problem and it's actually a very simple
calculation in fact this is some are
code I know it might be a little bit
difficult to to read but what this is is
a function that I created
it's called calculate attrition cost and
it takes a few different parameters and
then it performs just a vectorized
calculation that incorporates direct
costs lost productivity and some
assumptions in there and then also it
subtracts out the salary and benefits
which is what the company actually
benefits from losing an employee so for
a high-performing employee that is a
productive member of that company it can
be upwards of seventy eight thousand
dollars per employee that that company
loses when you assign a costume so the
funny thing that happens is is typically
companies don't just lose one person it
ends up being more of a systemic issue
and so what happens when a company such
as say you know Walmart or Target you
know a competitor moves in
starts stealing your high performers
before you know it you've got a couple
hundred that you've lost and if you lose
200 performers each year that's a 15
million dollar problem
yikes so we want to prevent these high
performers from leaving the company I
think that's pretty obvious by now so
way we can do that is through using data
signs and I'm gonna show you the the
product first just because I want to
show you guys the end result so we're
gonna do a quick shiny web app demo and
again this is something that's exclusive
to the art studio conference I'm really
excited about this this is what we're
developing as part of the 300 series
course so there's a 100 to 200 and 300
and those who take that course are gonna
be able to learn how to build this app
so I'm just gonna click this run app
button and if all goes well we get a
shiny app so what this app represents is
the end product you can imagine that
you've got managers out there that are
responsible for their employees they are
responsible for retaining them making
sure that they develop them into
productive people making sure that
they're happy and that's exactly what
this Apple allows us to do so I'm just
gonna scroll and kind of show you each
each one of these numbers represents a
specific employee and this particular
one employee number 891 has a 47%
prediction risk so this is this this
employee is actually predicted to leave
because that prediction risk is above
the threshold for deciding whether or
not that employee leaves and this is
actually h2o under the hood that's
generating this predictive model and the
app is encapsulating it so you can
imagine put yourself in that managers
shoes they see that they've got an
employee that's 47% likely to leave and
then what we have over here are the
reasons the features of why that person
is
predicted to leave so this is actually
comes from the line package and this
first feature here is stock options
that's that person has stock option
level 0 so this is something that the
manager can actually affect or a change
it's what's called a lever the it's a
feature that the manager can adjust so
maybe moving that employee from level
zero to level level one and giving that
employee stock options that might be
enough to help that employee to stay the
next one is the employee has over 28
years at the company the next one is
that the number of jobs that that
employee worked at is over 6 and then
the next one is that that person has a
training time last year of 2 so these
these two here are not levers that can
be adjusted you can't really toggle the
number of years that that employee works
or how many jobs that they've had
previously but that manager can then
take a look at maybe training times
maybe to help get them engaged give them
a few more training sessions a year so
this is really cool we're able to
actually bottle up data science into
this machine learning app and even
further than that we can develop
predictive recommendations that are able
to be presented to the manager so that
way they don't have to kind of think of
strategies to do but that's already
incorporated for them so for example
this management recommendation strategy
has a work environment strategy of
promote job engagement so that manager
should then focus on activities that
will promote job engagement so this is
what we're talking about when we provide
shiny web apps to non-technical
people business leaders that have a
stake in the game where they can
actually effect and make decisions that
better improve the company that can make
a huge difference so let's talk about
that next let's go here so this is what
I call the better decision-making effect
this is when you start to have you
provide the shiny web app to
the decision-makers in your company you
see that they're making you've trained
them on the app how to use it and you
see them making positive decisions what
ends up happening is as you monitor the
impact of the decision making
improvements you can start to see your
percentage of attrition going down down
and down so it starts up here around 20%
ending in about a year at 9% and then
you can actually use that cost of
attrition function to calculate how much
you're saving in the organization and
then how does that look when you show
your boss at the end of the year hey I
just saved you your company 4.3 million
dollars and that looks pretty good
and you'll probably get a I don't know
maybe a promotion out of it anyways the
better decision-making fact that's what
I want to get across here is that we can
use shiny apps to actually influence the
decisions within our own organizations
and that's how we generate business
value so what I want to talk about next
now is the data science workflow so we
talked a lot about the end product
hopefully you like the app and now what
I want to do is talk about the process
to get to that app so how do you go from
business problem to business value it
requires a process that is can be shown
as a workflow there's three stages
preparation experimentation and
distribution so in the preparation stage
you're acquiring data and you're
reformatting and cleaning data at that
stage then you move into the learning
which is the experimentation phase or
you've got your data you're coming up
with hypotheses you're meeting with
stakeholders in the company that know
that data inside and out to help you
develop your strategies and then you
move into the transformation and
visualization stage and then you get to
modeling and validation and then oh you
find ok we don't we aren't getting a
good model yet I got to go back and read
about re-evaluate our hypotheses or you
may have to go back and acquire data so
you've got kind of this process that's
iterative and eventually you get a model
that starts to show and prove
that gives you an idea that there could
be a possibility of changing decisions
you then move into that final phase of
distribution you develop reports you
convince people in the company executive
leadership that this is the right thing
to do and then you build an app and you
deploy it and you start getting those
business results so that's how you
generate business value what I want to
show you is the tidy verse is like it's
a perfect fit you can see that we've got
a bunch of packages that I've overlaid
you've got read are for reading and data
you've got deep liar tidier string our
[ __ ] date for at effort time series
stringer for text for cats for
categorical data to help you clean that
data you get into the experimentation
stage and once you're doing the
visualization and the transformations
you're working with deep liar in ggplot2
h2o once you get into the modeling and
validation and then you move into
reporting you've got our mark down and
then deployment you've got shine it just
fits and this is what I call the arc
tool chain it's a fabulous tool chain
I've been teaching it for quite a while
and I'll tell you what this gets results
so if we examine our workflow the plier
it's awesome for sizing the problem
identifying where we've got issues and
our data this particular analysis what
we're doing is looking within job roles
to define where we've got high cost of
attrition by cohorts within the data
ggplot2 imagine if you make a lollipop
chart like this and you show your
management that hey we've got a problem
here and you know what I've identified
where we've got that problem the sales
executive role three point nine two
million per year that's how much is
costing us we'd better try and obtain
some of those high performing sales
execs laboratory technician that's the
next one three point eight five million
we should focus on them then you get
into the modeling you've got h2o and
literally this is all the code that it
takes to make that model
so I want to give a quick shout out to
Aaron Liddell at h2o her team has done a
fabulous job to make a super scalable
high-performing machine learning
algorithm and literally this is called
automated machine learning it's
automated so it makes it super simple to
get all the models 20 different models
GLM's deep learning stacked ensembles
when they when they merge them all
together and average them gbm's they
have just done a really good job and
this is all it takes to start getting a
predictive model and then we need to
explain this feature so it's not good
enough to have a prediction
risk-management doesn't care about that
what they want to know is how can I
change my decision-making and this is
what lime gets you so this is all the
code literally it takes you to develop
that lime this is it and you make a lime
chart like that and you can see right
away that this employee has overtime
equals yes so maybe that their work-life
balance is out of whack maybe you should
look at that to try and retain them and
then shiny
you've got h2o lime deep liar and the
rest of the packages that's all under
the hood shiny is really the glue that
allows us to join everything together
and that's what I'm so excited about is
just that the shiny web infrastructure
makes everything so simple to get
business value business results so again
this is the data science workflow just
to recap you've got this amazing tool
chain and what that allows you to do is
build web apps that can change decisions
and then don't forget you need to
monitor those decisions and show the
savings that you're generating for the
organization all right real quick I just
showed you an amazing tool chain you're
probably wondering how do I learn all
this stuff well in my experience I've
been doing workshops and I've been doing
online education for quite a while now
learning art is like a hillclimb you
don't the the good data scientists
really focus on the fundamentals first
and then they move their way up the hill
so the fundamentals data cleaning and
manipulation that's learning like deep
liar tidier string art for text blue
bird eight
so on we've got visualization functional
programming advanced data science and
the goal which is the shiny or markdown
all right so before I end here I just
want to give you guys a quick bonus we
actually do have a number of courses
that we're developing strategically to
be able to help get you there if you
want to get there fast
it doesn't take years it takes weeks and
I even have a special bonus for you
we're giving everyone 15% off a business
science at University the promotional
code is our studio all right thanks
everybody for your time
[Applause]
[Music]